[Music]
my first time on Mars was unforgettable
after touring every corner of the earth
living in post-apocalyptic Boston and
studying at a dozen universities I
thought I had seen it all but well on
the ground on the Red Planet driving my
rover through the whippin dust that
giddy feeling of wonder swept over me
once again of course I wasn't actually
in any of these places but both my brain
and my body believed that I was and at
the end of the day is there really any
difference I'm talking of course about
virtual reality virtual reality has been
called many things from a passing fad
like 3d television to the next big
computing platform on the level of
mobile phones by now many of us have
already had the chance to try out VR
once or twice and have already started
to make assumptions about the impact
that it may or may not have but
regardless of your stance if I ask you
to picture who's actually using VR today
most of us will come up with an image
like this someone someone isolated in
their living room waving their arms
furiously in the air in between sips of
silence and handfuls of Doritos there's
a ton of stigma about VR people think
it's for gamers or claim that it's
overhyped or fear that it's going to
have unintended consequences on humanity
and for the record I think these are all
legitimate concerns but looking beyond
them there is so much more to virtual
reality and the promise that it holds I
believe in a future where VR will be
used around the world to improve
people's lives and bring us closer
together but we're a long way away from
that right now which leads us to the
biggest open question facing it today
what is it really for
or perhaps more importantly what can it
be for my own obsession with VR lies at
the heart of this question in my quest
to answer it I try to enter VR every
single day for the past few years even
if just for a few minutes at a time in
that time I've seen some things I've met
people and made real connections I've
used it as a tool to improve learning
and education and I've even built new
worlds and shared those experiences with
other people but regardless of the
specific application there's one
fundamental concept that makes VR so
promising to me and all of its
enthusiasts it's its ability to create
presence presence is achieved when your
brain truly believes that you're no
longer just standing in your bedroom or
your living room but somewhere else
entirely what VR is and will be for is
anything that requires presence and
especially when presence is either
expensive or even impossible to achieve
consider this we spend a tremendous
amount of time transporting our physical
brains to places that they're not think
of multi-hour commutes or
flying around the world just to go to a
meeting or two why do we do this it's
because being face to face with someone
feeling present in the same room matters
video conferencing was heralded as the
technology that was going to end the
office as we know it but it never
delivered on that promise because it
couldn't achieve presence but what if we
could create VR experiences that made
you truly feel like you're in that
meeting with those people how would our
concept of the commute or work in
general change
well presence is foundational what's
even more exciting is what we can build
on top of it the research shows that
when we were present in VR it actually
makes us feel like things are happening
to us as opposed to us just watching
them happen to someone
and when we can truly believe that we
are somewhere or even someone else we've
just entered the most powerful vehicle
for empathy that we've ever created now
let's pause and reflect for a moment why
did you all come here today to watch low
key notes instead of just catching it on
YouTube later it certainly can't be
because of comfort I'm sure your couch
is much nicer than these chairs and
definitely standing on almost all
metrics the at-home experience is better
than life except for one we come to live
events like these because we want to
feel something to absorb the energy of
the speaker and the people around us to
laugh and to cry and to share those
feelings with the people sitting next to
us in these live experiences it's our
presence that powers empathy but we
can't always come to live events just
like we can't always fly around the
world to understand how people live
their lives so it's you to achieve
presence we usually rely on reading
stories or watching videos but it's one
thing to read a story about Italy or to
see a picture of Rome or to even watch a
movie like gladiator but it's an
entirely different thing to step into
Julius Caesar shoes and see the world as
he did the research supports the fact
that when we have experiences even if
they're just simulated ones it makes us
much better connect with and understand
that content up to four times more than
if we were just to read about it or
watch it so well TV gives us a window to
peer into another world VR lets us step
into that world and truly immerse
ourselves in it it's an entirely new
medium for empathetic storytelling but
what stories can we tell consider clouds
over Sidra a VR experience built in
partnership with the United Nations and
presented at the World Economic Forum
the mission was to take global leaders
and help them better understand
what life is like for a young girl
living in a Syrian refugee camp and
inspire them to start making a
difference or consider melting ice a vr
documentary featuring al gore that
transports people to the remote parts of
the world that are most affected by
climate change to give them a vivid
understanding of the real impact that
it's already having VR is also being
used to combat domestic violence in a
recent study researchers have taken men
who have committed these acts and put
them into VR except in the body of a
woman
the men are then subjected to simulated
domestic violence and it's been proven
that it actually makes them more
empathetic to the others around them and
will hopefully prevent future incidents
these are just a few of the examples
that are possible now and every day
we're learning more about how we can use
VR as a tool to reimagine empathy well
I'm clearly just a little bit obsessed
about VR I don't think that it's me or
even anyone in this room who stands the
most to gain from it VR is going to
unlock experiences for the vast majority
of people in this world who don't have
access to them right now consider the
moment when anyone with a headset can
feel like they're sitting in a classroom
at a top university listening to
inspiring educators and having real
social interactions with the people next
to them that's the moment when we've
made world-class education available to
anyone the release of cheap but
high-quality VR headsets in the coming
years will make it possible for everyone
not just to feel greater empathy but to
have experiences that were previously
impossible for them to have so
regardless of the opinion about VR you
walked in with here today I encourage
you to broaden your perspective on what
it can and will be for much like how
black-and-white television or the first
mobile phone only hinted at what was to
come
VR is still very much in its infancy it
will take time but it's a future worth
building towards and in that future
everyone will have the ability to feel
present anywhere with anyone at anytime
and the human race will be much more
connected because of it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]